Adolf Hitler's easily one of the most
recognized names from history and has
come to me and almost a crazy ruler that
that causes its country to do crazy and
evil things but what I want to do in
this video is kind of understand where
how he got to where he was or at least
begin to understand how he got to where
he was so just to start at the beginning
he was born in 1889 and he's actually
Austrian by birth Austrians are Germans
ethnically and and they speak the German
language but they were not part of the
German Empire but at the break of World
War one so this would be in 1914 he
volunteers for the Bavarian army so at
this point he's 25 years old Bavaria was
part of the German Empire and over the
course of World War one is by most
accounts where Hitler first kind of
found meaning in life he was a dispatch
runner which means taking messages from
one theater of war to another from one
military officer to another he gets
quite decorated he he gets he gets
wounded in battle and and at the end of
the war which him and frankly a lot of
the military leadership of Germany blame
on being on kind of the traitors of the
civilian traitors as we remember as we
kind of enter into late 1918 in October
you have the revolution in Germany
Kaiser Wilhelm the second is overthrown
by civilian leaders and then in November
you have the Armistice and Hitler and
many of these and he was a fairly
low-level figure in the in the in the
German army at this time but even many
of the very senior figures and we'll
talk more about them like Ludendorff and
others they blamed Germany's defeat not
on just losing militarily to the Allied
powers they blamed it on kind of this
the stab-in-the-back theory that after
the Revolution the civilians who signed
this armistice they didn't have to that
they were being controlled by outside
influences and they would also start to
point it at the Jews in Germany and
saying that they were they were being
somehow influenced by people outside of
the country to try to get into an
armistice and they had this delusion
that Germany would have won the war if
if this November armistice would not
have actually been signed and they call
these civilians who signed the armistice
they call them the
member the November criminals November
criminals for betraying for betraying
the German nation so you could imagine
after the end of the war he found so
much meaning in the military that Hitler
stays in the military and just to get a
big picture of what happens we already
know you have your October Revolution
Germany becomes a republic they start
drafting a constitution at the same time
they start getting in the Allied powers
in Versailles start dictating the terms
of peace in June you have the Treaty of
Versailles comes into effect and we've
already talked about this but Germany
loses a significant amount of its
territory it has to pay reparations now
and maybe most humiliating for the
Germans it is the full guilt of the war
is placed on Germany shoulders now
shortly after that Hitler is is an
officer in the military he is assigned
to essentially spy to infiltrate on the
German Workers Party which is not a big
deal at the moment this is a party that
has around 50 members so he's just been
given the responsibility hey keep track
of what what these characters are doing
shortly after that you have the whyme
our Constitution gets gets gets gets
written and passed and if they're a
whole reason the reason why it's called
the whymark Constitution is that it was
drafted in the town of Y Mar and this is
the Constitution now of the German
Republic which would be known as the
Weimar Republic because it's based on
the whymark Constitution which was
drafted in the town of Y Mar and even
though Hitler joined in 1919 in 1919 is
kind of to to spy on these guys he's
actually quite impressed by the German
Workers Party which is hugely
nationalist which is it's it's it's it's
in line with this whole blaming World
War Ones loss on these on these November
criminals these civilian leaders who
betrayed the German army it's
anti-semitic its anti-jewish its
anti-communist and it's anti-capitalist
and it's interesting here because a lot
of times when people talk about things
people like Nazis and fascists they
often talk about them as these far-right
parties but when people talk about left
and
they're usually talking in economic
terms so when you talk about someone on
the Left you're talking about usually
someone you know if the extreme left
you're talking about a communist someone
who believes in no classes that there
shouldn't be a rich and a poor that
maybe not even any private property and
if you talk about someone at the far
right so this is the left and if you
talk about someone at the far right
you're usually talking about someone who
believes in kind of free-market
economics who you know who's a a
capitalist India extreme and the the
nationalist philosophy and as we'll see
the fact the fascist philosophy coming
out of Italy and the Nazi philosophy
that would come out that the Nazis
essentially are what the German Workers
Party would evolve into it was different
than either one of these this was
actually all about all about your
nationality and in particular from their
point of view their race of as being a
stronger race as the government being a
strong government that's all about the
promotion of that race all about the the
the the expansion of that state which is
based on its races power about the
purity of the race so to a large degree
they were they were against a lot of
these a kind of these extreme forms of
either left-wing Marxist communist
philosophies or even pure capitalism but
anyway he joins as the 55th member so as
you see at this point in time it's not
really a significant organization and
then in 1920 in 1920 in order to have
more appeal especially on the
nationalist side of things they renamed
themselves instead of just being the
German Workers Party and the acronym is
da P because when I read German Workers
Party I'm just saying what it did the
translation would be in English but then
in 1920 they changed their name to the
nationalist Socialist German Workers
Party or the NSDAP and the the word Nazi
comes from nationalists the way it was
pronounced and I'm sure I'm going to do
it wrong Nazi no the National so you
could imagine the Nazi know if you just
say the first part you'd pronounce it as
Nazi and early on even in in 1919 and
especially in 1920 a Hitler gets
recognized by the party leadership is
someone with
very very powerful or rhetorical
abilities every time he makes an
argument he gives a speech it seems like
people are listening and so he gets more
and more more and more pull and sway in
the party he actually is the the
individual who designed the logo for the
Nazi Party put this swastika right over
here and the swastika is really an
interesting symbol we now associate it's
almost a scary symbol for it for those
of us in the West because it represents
all of what the Nazi Party ended up
representing but it's actually an
ancient symbol that comes out of Hindu
traditions it comes out of kind of
traditions out of the the well Aryan
traditions and and this whole this whole
myth that Hitler constructed was about
this Aryan race which was a superior
race which was the cause of everything
all of the advancement that civilization
has ever done he was an he considered
the Germans as kind of the pure pure
version of the Aryan race he was a
little bit confused Aryans are much more
alive but you know Iran if Persians are
much more indicative of Aryans and even
Indians and but the swastika was a
symbol of auspiciousness of good luck
for the Aryans and if you go to a Hindu
temple you might see a swastika it does
not mean what you think it means it
means actually something very positive
but Hitler adopted it he actually wanted
to replace the cross because to him and
represented not a belief system it
represented a a bloodline it represented
an ethnic tradition that he thought he
viewed the Germans as being the purest
versions of so it's a very fascinating
symbol and you know don't get scared if
you see this used by by by by Hindus or
some other tradition they don't they
don't mean it in the Nazi in the Nazi
sense
but regardless Hitler gets more and more
and more power by 1921 he's recognised
is essentially the most influential
member when he threatens to quit because
of kind of divisions happening in the
party they recognize that the party
would be lost without him because he's
such a he's such a powerful speaker and
so they they make him chairman so at
this point in 1921 you have Hitler as
head as chairman of the Nazi Party and
as time goes on he's giving more and
more and more speeches he's able to
attract more and more people to the
party although it's still a very small
party we're talking in in the hundreds
of members and now the thousands of
members and while this was hope
happening in the early 20s the
conditions in Germany itself continued
to deteriorate
why maar Germany in particular is
deterring deteriorating economically as
we've already talked about the Treaty of
Versailles they're having to ship
they're having to ship resources to the
the Allies the in order to pay
reparations the Weimar Republic is
essentially just printing money
converting it into other currency and
then paying the receipt reparations with
that other currency and it's one of the
most famous examples of just
hyperinflation this is the value of one
gold mark and paper marks so the paper
marks was the currency of the Weimar
Republic and you could see that as you
go especially from around 1919 and 1920
to 1922 and 1923 it was devalued not by
a million not even by a thousandfold a
million fold or billion fold it was
devalued by nearly a trillion fold so
the paper was just becoming worthless
this was causing huge huge instability
in the economy and you have multiple
attempts at overthrowing the government
Hitler wasn't the first multiple Poots
and I know I'm mispronouncing it were
attempted puste is the German word for
coup d'etat and so as you get into 1923
Hitler himself feels emboldened multiple
attempts were made in 1922 in 1922 you
have Mussolini does the march on Rome
the fascists come to power so he sees
that as an example so let me write that
down and we'll do another video on that
march on march on Rome so then in 1923
Hitler is actually able to get some
support of some pretty notable people
especially right this gentleman right
over here Erich Ludendorff Ludendorff
was one of the two gentlemen who was in
charge of the German military during
World War one but he was also one of
these believers and estab in the back
theory that they would have one
war if the if the if the civilians who
were apparently according to him
controlled by the Jews didn't surrender
that Germany would have somehow
magically have won the war he's able to
get Ludendorff support and he attempts
to essentially overthrow the government
first of Bavaria and then take over the
German government so he attempts this
what's known as the Beer Hall Putsch
tore the beer hall coup d'etat in 1923
and in a Munich Beer Hall actually
visited it about ten or twelve years ago
it's an interesting visit it's it
usually is on the tourist map when you
when you go to Munich and it's a failure
he had Ludendorff support but it's a
failure they try to march on the next
morning after the the failed beer hall
pooched and a bunch of Nazis are
actually shot and then arrested
including including Adolf Hitler and so
a night at the is by 1924 he is thrown
in prison and in nineteen while he's in
prison is when he's essentially he
dictates his his beliefs and his
autobiography in meine Kampf which is
translated as my struggle and it's an
interesting document to look at it's
actually banned in in some countries and
not not in the US but and it's it's
available on the web because when you
look at it it it's really you could kind
of see how Hitler at one level was an
amazing communicator but on another
level was in was a was essentially a
troubled mind a very demented mind it
who had very had a very skewed belief
system but this passage right over here
is one of many in the book that kind of
encapsulates his views of the world if
we pass all the causes of the German
collapse and review the ultimate and
most decisive remains the failure to
recognize the racial problem and
especially the Jewish menace so he's
seeing this lack of racial purity and
somehow the Jews are keeping the Germans
from from winning wars the defeats on
the battlefield in August 1918 would
have been child's play to bear they
stood in no proportion to the victories
of our people it was not they that
caused our downfall
no it was brought about by that power
which prepared these defeats by
systematically over many decades robbing
our people of the political and moral
instincts and forces which alone make
nations capable and hence worthy of
existence in heedlessly ignoring the
question of the preservation of the
racial foundations of our nation the old
Reich disregarded the sole right which
gives life in this world and if you read
a lot of it all he talks about is the
reason why Germany lost this war the
reason why Germany was in the position
that it's in after World War one this
humiliating position isn't because it
didn't have the most powerful military
isn't because the Germans aren't the
most powerful race in the history of
humanity they're the the purest
descendants of the the Aryan people it's
because they weren't pure enough it's
because they allowed themselves to
somehow be muddied racially and so this
huge mythology that he constructs it it
starts with the assumptions that the
Germans left to their own devices would
not have left this war and he obviously
starts to blame it on other causes
including somehow not being racially
pure